o pobre não sabe agir em conjunto eles
começam a fazer as coisas não dá C
minutos estão brigando pega ess pisca
pisca aqui vai desenrolando vai vai
puxando ali PR botar na tomada vai ó
bestado ó o burro ó o burro Vai rasgar
burro ei mãe ó o me chamando de burro
aqui rapaz rapaz se eu foria eu vou
botar essa árvore t no de você rapaz
João João João fala com esses meninos
Rapaz tu não faz nada dentro de casa
rapaz eu tô cansado rapaz Acabei de
chegar t t Trabalhando rapaz vocês
também não não me ajuda não né rapaz ô
vai chamar Men eu não tenho sossego
nessa casa nãoé burro desse aí
burro aí Men Obrigado rapaz mas ser
possível chamando faz nada pegar o
filado meu Deus dificuldade pegar um
F